when you were you growing up in your
head even at like age five or six
there's a clear distinction between like
Pokemon and like I don't know like
Cartoon Network that that was a
difference and and you knew that they
one of them was Japanese yeah yeah yes
like I because unlike a lot of kids in
Australia and like probably around my
age group I grew up watching Pokemon and
like Dragonball Japanese I've thought
Pokemon was an American cartoon and I
owe people did my mind was blown at like
age ten when I heard the Japanese
version this is on YouTube clips right
I'm like oh wait this is the original
yeah how because to me Pokemon when I
was growing up just seemed like this
very weird genre like I couldn't put my
finger on yeah but I felt like it was a
genre like it was pokemon digimon
cardcaptor sakura which is cardcaptors
in the UK in america sakura that's true
asian sound get rid of that sakura
sakura and the other girl was like they
changed her name to madison I think I
can't remember her original name was but
this is this is back in the age of like
for kids dubbing I don't think it was
even even for kids that dubbed
Cardcaptor Sakura but it was in the day
that's you know localization was a thing
we are eating jelly doughnuts cuz you
know like being as you said like growing
up in an Asian household Japanese
household when the idea was just like
the most like normal concepts like your
breath it's like you know like yeah as
you said it's like bread it's like
watching an American content like
Dexter's Laboratory yeah like a scene of
them making toast for example and it's
over dubbed into Japanese way you know
I'm making a rice ball I think it's just
cause at that time I remember a lot of
my friends just didn't really know the
concept of just eating rice yeah if you
want if you want Asian you're like why
would you eat rice with every meal that
doesn't make sense right right I think I
can remember what my family thinking
like rice was like exotic isn't really
well I mean it was something you had a
good like foreign food yeah
so you don't eat rice but like that's on
the contrary the right way do you eat
bread with everything because at least
in Japan the concept of white bread with
everything is like why I feel like at
least in British culture you could put
bread with anything like you just wear
that I guess I guess like the food
culture of that country revolt anyway
we're getting off topic